the protein evacuees you actually green
really fast now and we are at the point
that we can design protein structures
but the challenge is now people facing
is to design the proteins with the
embedded functions like if one of these
design enzyme to do that is American
thing like to cut peptide bond or
two-stage kept it together you don't the
design lab that's hard as a real hard
because protein function will fully
function it's a dynamic process it's not
like sorry right right it's not just sit
there and do nothing
it actually moves around and do things
the how you design this dynamic thing is
really hard to be able to develop that
kind of therapeutics you can't get away
from making the mirror image protein
molecules you want to make that calamita
in new technologies that's what we're
doing for us we will collaborate with
the people life science school of
science arresting or seeing other
people's to other people too we will see
like which molecule which targets is the
most irrelevant like therapeutic targets
or it's the most like medically on net
make needs for patients we focus we
identify lacks first and then we use all
the approaches we have know someone's
opinion may contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we in what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saucon we're on site
at the beautiful West Lake University in
Hangzhou China we are now going to be
talking about protein technologies we
have dr. Bobo dong joining us on the
show hybl oh hi thank you so much for
coming on the show so really appreciate
it that I'm so excited to have you for
those who don't know Bobo's background
he's an assistant professor and
principal investigator at West Lake
University focused on protein synthesis
and engineering and you can find his
links in the bio below okay Bobo let's
start things off by asking one of our
favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
yeah I mean the world is moving forward
for sure and then I think I think the
meaning of the world is just like it
needs to provide opportunity for every
single human being to explore the
unknown nature of like science
maybe territory to the owner world and
then to do that you have to have a like
healthy lifespan to enable yourself to
to dialect for example myself if I got
an injury I can't go out into things
right so we do have the maybe the health
system or maybe the technologies to
enable the society can ensure or provide
the like stage for everybody to do that
and then for us like working in the like
produ science or like help power
technologies of Pharma pharmacology is
like and other things we are the people
to do that like to to come up with
strategies or like different ways like
to repair people to treat people when we
really don't have like the healthy body
so I think I'll be dedicated my career
to like to this goal like to people who
wants to explore the world and then to
make sure like these people are in the
healthy states and then we can do that I
think
I think that would be mango actually so
how to do that how to do that of course
there are different ways like particular
from the approach a say you can either
develop like technologies like make
certain little surgeries right they fix
people and then people like me like with
your love life for the therapeutics
which is like leaving like technology in
the 21st century like to treat patients
like so if I cancer to like and other
diseases so I'll be working about you
yeah there's two thoughts there one of
them is increasing the basic needs for
everyone around the world to be able to
actualize their unique gift and
potential I love that and then the other
one is the the ability to be able to
make targeted therapeutics for tackling
some of the biggest complex diseases
that we have to prevent pathologies from
developing in the first place to stay
healthy longer so you can be more
creative past more time with their
families find more meaning all this kind
of cool stuff yeah how about your
journey who were you as a kid growing up
how did you get interested in science
and proteins yeah I think for me myself
I think it's all it's always about like
curiosity like like growing up a think
I'm pretty curious about like different
things like I mean I go out in the field
I look at things like I wonder why Pete
what what thing what burst-fire like
what something can see the color like
the fair fire rate how does it work I
mean I'm always curious about these
things like I mean why go to school
cross a lot of science and then I do
pretty good science too and especially I
was attracted to chemistry so that's
what I loved most and like pretty much
since seems like undergrad at took the
chemistry at major and then a undergrads
I think I developed interest you know
like especially in peptides and proteins
because I mean these are the things that
made up the human body like made up like
pretty much the living living world so I
was really into these things and trying
to figure out how the
work and then maybe if we can if people
can do something with that like some
interest of things maybe at that time I
wasn't really sure like well I can I can
contribute to this like proteins are so
big like if you can how do you like make
therapeutics you need protein molecules
how do you like even manipulate things
like maybe maybe you like create life
like something existing the words I mean
back then I wasn't sure right but then
gradually I dropped the interest and
then I try to start him one more like
after my undergrad I felt I really love
protein so I I want to make protein
molecules just like no organic chemistry
making that small molecule straight so I
went to Chicago and joined to the Steve
Cannes lab okay right before we get to
Chicago yeah so I love this young bubble
that I'm envisioning right now that's
constantly going and finding the why is
it birds fly why is it that this is this
way that is that way how do I you know
ask these questions so you can
understand the reality that you were in
and then it was this this understanding
that you know if maybe if you can
understand proteins which proteins make
up is it all of life's functioning most
event mostly is functioning right that's
so interesting and so we'll be breaking
that down and so then you that was kind
of a big like ultimate why is like you
know why is that and then how can I be
an engineer in that space of proteins
okay I like that
and then now yes so then okay after
doing Amnon Jane University was where
you did your bachelor's then you decided
to move this is a big move to the
University of Chicago so I want you to
explain to us you were there until you
did your PhD in chemistry there and
we'll talk about what you were doing but
first let's talk about how did you
decide to move to the United States and
also what was it like when he first
arrived yeah
I think the nature of myself is just
like I'd like to explore things like I
mean I could I'd like to go up my friend
explore like things to like for the
science aspect it's the same like I was
I mean I will study in China but like
it's it's not too much a last back then
I think the leading the B be the leading
force is still in the u.s. so I I wanted
to go to the US and see what's up there
and just see like if I find like things
getting more interesting or not so I
decided to go to the US and then I also
fits my personal interests cuz I like to
explore different things I want to see
the world right you see like what are
other people doing what other cultures
like swear I went to the US and then I
joined the lab the lab was actually
really good Custer the pea I was like
was really like close to people's I'm
being like it's like he also done it
like really tell people what to do so
you're just like it's just like you have
a lab and they explore yourself to see
what were you are you taste and then
decide what to do and when I first got
it got to the US so the lab was actually
really good apart from the lab like in
the you know in my personal life it's
it's one little bit difficult I will say
because my English was not this good
Batman I can't really quite talk to
people like all time so that took me
some time so I try to I mean I just I
like to go out and talk to people and
then have fun with people so that's how
I trying to like merge into the society
Amber's like just make your friends and
then and then go like gradually see like
gradually like they all open like like
relationships with the different people
and then eventually with the society and
I feel like I'm I'm actually pretty
comfortable in there
yeah cuz like the u.s. I think in the
spirit many was like in the spirit of
the of the nation like they actually go
explore the world I think that's
actually rooted in u.s.
I like that too so I'm like the same so
I like God and I I mean I like the life
present life I like lab too so it's
actually appropriate fear for me yes yes
and then when you're there what does
this mean protein ion channel light
Lions oh right yeah so that's a that's a
mouthful
yeah not many things in there so first
like I should give you some introduction
let's do the introduction yeah yeah
animals yeah like we're all familiar
with like almost like spiders scorpions
right and these are like I mean we see
them all the time and then we know that
dangerous because if you got B tail or
if you got stung by these things you got
hurt some people get killed by those
things but what really happens for these
things but these animals they make some
like pretty small protein molecules and
these molecules we can actually interact
with the like channels which are
memorable TSL so this protein when
animal by you I was telling you the
inject these are little like missiles
into your body and these small proteins
go out and find these like round
channels and then they either block with
their own channels there you cannot feel
anything you see you become long some of
them become really like nasty like they
stop the block down channel demodulate
the function eventually like people
might lose those handle those the lyrics
so those are actually like really
interesting molecule they could they
could be really dangerous but because we
these molecules the function against
this like ion channels or like other
cell memory receptors so they were
actually harvest by like scientist to
study these like receptors around
channels because traditionally you have
any ways to study those rate only we
have a tour to like change the function
or alter the function of these proteins
you can study them so people have been
like actually trying to make this
feel so even like isolate them and then
try to probe how these like different
sound channel work and then like I mean
are to today people are doing that and
be thing is because the the function
against these like receptors they can
actually be developed our therapeutics
and there's why conotoxin
I think it's like LG Jie and Jacek
agents like people you died to treat
pain like up until today actually there
are like a big group of people like
including many forms so the companies
they are trying to develop like like
molecules including a small molecules
also these kind of small protein
molecules to target the specific vector
sodium channels to treat pain and it's
like there are some I think there are
some clinical trials going on and I
expect there will be there will be
future therapeutic for that damn so
there's vitamins biology evolved a
snakes scorpions spiders all those stuff
to have some of them have a most of them
have it
most of them have most of them has it
you have a protein molecule that many
different ones that the many different
ones not just one just one just wow and
and uh and it's so it evolved so that
they themselves could once they bit a
mammal like no like a rodent like oh
like a rat or like a yeah thing like
that yeah yeah that it works against all
mammals I guess it works against all
potentially man yes and then as soon as
it but then that would paralyze it or
something along those lines and they
could then eat it and whoa so okay so
then we have the potential to take that
out of the creature and then begin doing
tests on exactly where how that causes
the harm to us and then we can then
engineer strategies to prevent that from
working and so
I do believe there was another company
that at Indy bio that I was helping as
well in one of the batches of the no-mix
that was doing some interesting
assisting for people especially in parts
of the world that have these venomous
creatures to prevent them from getting
the venom issues arise yeah that's
because there's there's I believe it was
in the millions of people worldwide
because there's all different types of
venomous yeah yeah yeah
and so okay then it was this is great
you came to San Francisco yeah yeah to
UCSF for his postdoc yeah he came to
over to Silicon Valley and that was for
four years doing computational protein
design for new protein structures yeah
okay so teach us about this so also like
computers are now able to do protein
design yeah yeah so after I did my PhD I
learned like all technologies of protein
molecules right if there's there is just
like you can name a protein I can study
any any maybe not any but most of them
most of them yeah so I got the
technologies to see the size many of the
protein is right and how many teams
I seen advised are there you are there
yeah so a human body there are about
20,000 genes that encode like tiny
foreign proteins in human body is it a
one-to-one ratio the G's means like open
reading frames means one gene to one
protein yeah let's talk about the
product the different cells like some
other protocol experience other proteins
may not be expressed but in total people
have these many proteins and that could
be expressed in human body by H versus
you just specific cell I'm not sure I'm
not sure but total amount if that and
maybe even before we do the on
computational protein design yeah we
were starting to venture into this and I
think it would be helpful to to also
like break this down a little bit
more so okay people are pretty familiar
with at least they understand DNA most
people at least get the DNA yeah and
then we have the nucleotides in DNA AST
c's and g's now and then this acts as a
code within us that can then be used to
make amino acids which then make
proteins and amino acids are in Chains
right and those amino acids then fold
into the proteins okay and the body is
all all there's like never so there's
literally never a moment your whole life
your body's constantly reading these
letters of DNA making amino acids
putting them into chains make having
those fold into proteins to do things
for you all the time all the time every
minute every second every second yeah it
just keeps going like I mean protein
although eventually the function
functional players are like all human
activities whether list yeah list some
of these functional activities that
proteins do with the human body
yeah right like like the ion channels we
just talked about like in the neuron
will have that like when I move my hand
right the new your brain is to send a
signal to my muscle to the muscle and
then the muscle received the signal then
like my hand to move I can see you these
all function like at the protein that
like in the neurons there are like these
own channels and when you give a
stimulus of their own channel the ion
channel opens and they gives you like
like a electronic signal and this
extended tronic signal passed down
through the through the neurons through
the axons and they eventually pass to
your to your muscles and then like your
muscle can move so proteins are a
massive part of our nervous system
there's every single one of our cells of
our young cells of course every cell
yeah every cell in our body has
many proteins are in every cell of our
body like thousands of proteins
well of course more more than thousands
of proteins in every cell well I think
one of morning's I'm not sure like how
many but it's it's full of like it's
full of proteins like if you think about
if you think of a couple cup of water
right look the water filled up the cup I
mean it's always like these water
molecules in the cell it's sex similar
situation whoa
all these different proteins they pretty
much filled up your like sent yourself
yeah so so a filled up cup of water has
h2o molecules just oh and then the cell
also has filled with different
biological components right sis filled
it's all filled up although it's not
like the empty space here like you get
some empty space in the cell there's no
empty space technically this is also
like I mean technically there is no
empty space there's no it is what I mean
yeah yeah if you think us like ma like
proteins yeah if you think of it like a
cell right yeah yeah now it's like these
cameras there's being protein molecules
it will not be this situation in the in
the cell if it's what we feel what we
filled up like you and me and this desk
and everything yeah yeah I mean interact
with each other all the time
yeah yes so so this is interesting so
the just like there's an encoded
sequences in our DNA to then make the
amino acids which again there are
encoded sequences of amino acids which
make specific proteins there's some how
proteins are smart themselves and then
the cell is smart itself people think
okay well it means that a cell is smart
at least you know it that that one we've
had some episodes where we've talked
about the intelligence of the cells but
yeah but the protein inside the cell is
intelligent it knows what's happening in
the cell outside yeah I'm
this if you really think hard I mean if
you really think deep it goes to B goes
to backdoor original life right how did
life go evolved part of life become
possible like all these protein
molecules it got I mean from evolution
it's it it's all get evolved to like up
until today but then like how they start
in the beginning I'm not sure if people
know that like it starts in the
beginning there is only be say else
molecules like there's no life just
maybe there's no there's no proteins and
then somehow I got it gets evolved and
then like bones make pounds and then you
come up with these like smaller maybe
smaller segments and then somehow these
smaller segments assemble together and
then at one point to form cell but then
how why why things work like this like
how did protein go evolved like to have
this function like now we have like so
many protein have so many different
function but why well I don't know I
don't know I don't know if we can come
up with a solution to that how I ended
up with like thousand of yeah holy all
you might have and not being like oh we
are yeah yeah I don't know I don't know
about I don't know how to figure that
out but like I mean people have to do
any research like to see like how these
simple things become like complications
there's lots of people working on the
simplicity evolving to complexity and
simulating that process yeah just so
fascinating yeah and then we ourselves
could potentially launch another
simplicity again and what evolve and
trillions of them just watch them evolve
you know it's such a beautiful beautiful
creation maybe yeah if we understand
enough of this system right if if
eventually if even surely we can
understand a system maybe like I said it
in the Box you kill the basic elements
and then you feed the information that
you know that you learned from all the
system may be in this isolated box you
can evolve a life-form be so cool right
yeah yeah okay now that's far away from
the topic this is it's right there with
the biology and evolution and how
proteins work so so now how did we let's
let's also let's also hit this one along
the way how did we figure out the
individual components of the cell as
well how many years ago was that last 30
a long time ago 50 years ago not 50 more
than 400 100 yeah must be 100 and in the
more cell biologists like I can't I
can't tell you two specific things on
that but it's been a long time and it
may seem like yeah 50 60 years ago
people figure out the DNA codes
exactly nice and quick yes but before
that people know there are people know
there are DNA star proteins
people knew those don't you is time if
you can isolate the oil proteins of it
just don't know how it works it's
understanding the mechanism is different
than knowing the molecule exists right
oh so we figured out the molecule
existed we knew that for a while but we
didn't know how the mechanism yeah I
mean I mean France is a quickly solve
for the DNA structure that's call we
know how DNA oh how DNA work but before
that I mean people how I said it'd be
nice otherwise they can't have the DNA
together structures so that goes no no
no I'm back yeah and then so then most
recently then we figured out that that
proteins in a sense are kind of like
building blocks there there are
different proteins that can that do
different things within our bodies that
are critical to the functioning of life
and then then there's launching the
computational capacities now of silicon
and chips to be able to
to design two designs yeah okay so is
this mean like there's like a natural
biological dislike there's 20,000
protein designs that firfer from all of
biology or just humans no for humans is
20,000 but other lives maybe maybe
bacterias they have different number of
practitioners have different yeah
because that's where we that's where we
find CRISPR yeah yeah so we can still
find really cool things and like
bacteria so thank you thank you might
have maybe more like tens of thousands
more you think I mean some of the
protein will be similar so they might be
home a lot but there are different ones
I mean many of the like all technology
were actually like intact or like
partially contributed by these
algorithms like the PCR reaction the
deep honor is the design that the the
real PC the real deep on without make
peace our or isolated from I think our
key us it's not from human man human
polymerase doesn't work like that yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah okay and then then now
there's a natural let's say in both
microbial plus human right etc um more
evolved life earlier life and latter
evolved life there's an array of
proteins that exist and then there's
ones that we make that are not found in
biology right yeah yeah cause like for
to make the like the truly normal ones
that's not fun in nature I mean it's
possible to do that now at this moment
because we have the computational power
to design protein it's like to design
the structures that we want like if you
have a protein structure that you want
to design using to your commutation
approaches you can do that now it's
totally possible and you're doing this
at UCSF we did that our UCSF for
molecule
like with designs a protein molecule
that has a unnatural component to the
protein with divine dots to have the
unnatural component and then after we
did the design we actually we actually
did the experiment to validate if the
Dena was successful or not
so you eventually determine the
structure and turn out to be like pretty
much the same as we designed so the
protein did not come easier you actually
green really fast now and we are at the
point that we can design protein
structures like if I do different
structure we can do that but the problem
the talent is now people are facing is
to design the proteins with embedded
functions like if what we design enzyme
to do that is the marry thing like to
cut peptide bond or to stage kept it
together
we don't have B than that that's hard
that's real hard cuz protein function
when pruning function it's a dynamic
process it's not like a sorry right
right it's not just sit there and do
nothing
it actually moves around and do things
but how you design this dynamic thing is
really hard but that's the that's the
thing the scientists are doing at this
moment ok so then you got your
understandings of computational protein
design and chemical synthesis you've got
your footing in those and then you were
like okay I'm going to take this
opportunity to come to Westlake right ok
so now tell us about the transition to
Westlake how did that come up after the
postdoc and why did you take the
opportunity and what are you guys doing
now in the lab yeah so we do whole
stocks at some point you realize you
have too many ideas to the point that
you just saw two IDs you you can't work
although what every single one of them
right at that point you know maybe it's
time to move on it's time to just start
all over and get people and work on
those
so that's pretty much how I felt when I
was finishing up my postdoc and looking
for academic jobs and then for me I
thought I mean the rhythm I go back
China is my things because I'm Chinese I
grew up in here I like the things here
I like the u.s. too but I thought
eventually I'll move back to China so
that's one grade another release like
China is investing a lot in science
subtracted like global talents not just
Chinese like across all nations so I saw
the opportunities so I took it and I
thought with the resources we have here
I will be able to do the things that I
want to do so I was like my research
group has four different components Y
will be like under protein chemical
positions these parts because there are
I mean people have been working on this
for the call about a century all the way
back from like in official make that
I've kept a bond to like oxytocin
synthase to like solid phase purposes
and then little chemical ligation to
make proteins but at this moment it's
still hard to make it's still hard
challenging to make real protein
molecules that's like a big size like
the biggest one with me up until today
is like less than 400 amino acids long
the peptide chain that's now 400 a ski
that will took years to do okay we let
explain this to UM is a is a peptide in
an amino acid an amino acid is a peptide
no a peptides is a chain of amino acids
okay so so so a peptide is a chain of
amino acids and you are giving this
example earlier where it's hard to make
them synthesize a protein that can cut
no peptide no to to make a protein
that's like 410 I say that's that much
now I thought I was mentioning earlier
yeah okay yes yes so currently most of
the
proteins that are made by our bodies are
made with amino acid chains peptide
chains of 200-300 know that's also the
if you think about so proteins could
some protein do you have just one
function domain which means just one
thing and they function so that size
will be around maybe 200 300 I mean I
say it's if they have one function
see how one function of domain some
proteins pick up a bunch of these things
whoa so they become really big yeah like
don't tell us we talked about yeah it's
over a thousand I mean Isis now like the
DNA polymerase we talked about the
people using the lab PCR so a thousand
emulous is long I mean those are a lot
of things that beyond beyond the
technology we have at this moment but we
are synthesizing to 300 we are yeah
chain amino acids and in there folding
into proteins yeah hold into protein
with high efficiency right now with high
efficiency right but it still takes time
like if you want to synthesize a protein
of like 300 amino acids it's not the
thing that you can do in a week or month
the product take a year or even longer
to do it takes a year yeah why it's just
like I mean it's just like you need to I
mean will the thing about proteins in
the phase you are starting from
individual components you start why I
mean I see you to the second is the
third you make a peptide chain which may
be like now 50 MLS is now but that's not
big enough right proteins like 200 300
the only making like 50 40 so the
technology to do that is just you make
the bunch of them and you make the
individual pieces wait you can't come to
me computationally make those can I like
assign a robot to make that we have
robots yes we have robots I mean we got
the robot here they make the change for
you but there you need to stage the
chance together oh there's no
humans still have to stitch the chains
yeah we have to do the reactions and
then doing the purifications why can't
robots do the chase stitch the chains
and do the purification right we haven't
I mean if you what not we just don't
have it like we don't have one yet
that's like there are things there are
things you need to think about we do
this kami it's all chemistry but you're
interesting about how to do this
chemistry it requires a lot in the year
I think it will come up yeah yeah I
might spend some time on that that's an
interesting one yeah but uh I mean but
there are there are other ways to go
around that's okay yeah and like how to
hug do you fish how to efficiently make
the proteins like a big size beyond 300
amino acids and you have to stitch the
peptide chain so they actually they
actually make the natural natural bounds
actual bonds right how do they bond how
do the peptide chains bond so it's it's
a my bonds
it's a my bond between peptide but the
the reaction we do now
it's actually invented by my PhD adviser
so we call it native chemical ligation
so right you have all you have Y Amir
acids on the n-terminus which is because
his t the other side you have all
because our ester so just develop them
together in water and then they just
come together that's it pretty simple
but how do you if you want to have like
70 pieces of all those things stitching
together there are no it becomes
complicated yeah that's why it takes
time and that's what that was for one
protein oh yeah right okay so and now we
we want proteins that have like a
thousand amino acids because they do
like fiver they do more things yeah like
like for example in this in this
community people are trying to
synthesize the mirror image version of
the proteins like why we do that one
thing is that if you want if you make
the mirror image versions maybe you can
explore maybe the just a different
universal life
I mean people from my university did
work on that and more than more people I
believe are working on that to like
eventually if you can make if a chemical
a sinner face this mirror image proteins
even like creating a mirror image life I
don't know I don't know how relevant
that is to the thing worth doing now but
I thought it's really cool you come up
with that maybe you can see how that
interact with like the natural things
okay please don't be pretty fun I think
another reason is there's one direction
people do is we try to make mirror image
protein therapeutics which is a totally
unnatural like the human human body
never saw that we're trying to make a
protein the human body's never seen our
saying and you thank you God you have a
therapeutic rights okay yeah yeah yeah
it's like you know okay I mean that
longitudinal testing yeah yeah yeah I
mean we might just just go into the body
until the thing and then just uh don't
cause anything okay to make sure it does
the thing of course of course he your
force needs to go through like a early
development and then doing some animal
studies usually I mean maybe to in
clinical trials and people including
like my PhD advisor deep they've done
some of the work I still is still going
up this field is there a chemical that's
is there is there protein that's been
chemically synthesized that is already
being used in the FDA no no yet this is
like a new thing this is a real living
you
Wow that will be very profound for the
first one that gets approved yeah it
won't be really it will be really cool
yeah yeah whoa so thing about that if
you want to develop that kind of protein
therapeutics you have to I guess that'll
be complicated you have to actually make
the mirror image version of the natural
proteins to do that I can't explain
to details but it's actually
requirements you need to make the
natural protein targets at the mirror
universe
- for you to be able to develop that
kind of therapeutics so you can't get
away from making the mirror image
protein molecules you want to make that
how do you make that you need new
technologies that's what we are doing
mmm and so then is it that even the the
the chemically synthesized protein would
still need to have the mirror image of
the one that's inside of our body
because it would need to potentially do
the effect it wants to do through that
protein yes so so the mirror image
therapeutic we events will come up with
right it will interact with people so
they will interact with the natural
things yeah yeah okay yeah how does your
lab figure out what proteins it wants to
chemically synthesize there's obviously
some unlimited option so yeah how do you
figure this out yeah so we have to work
with the biologists like that's also the
reason why I joined the school life
sciences at Westlake universities so
most of the like most of the therapeutic
development I think the biology most of
time on the biology goes first
like I mean especially for the targeted
approaches you have one you need to
develop the maybe a signaling pathway
like or like a therapeutic target you
have a target right and then you try to
develop markers to work on the target
like target if they're abilities like
now like in your checkpoint and here
there's like those are focused on that
specific target so you have you have
this target and then maybe you work on
these targets for us or collaborates
with the people at the life science life
science school of science arresting you
know stealing other people's to other
people too and we will see like which
molecule which target
if the most irrelevant like therapeutic
target or it's the most like medically
unmet make needs for the patient's
before we identify that's first and then
we use all the approaches we have do you
have any ideas what those targets might
be I mean our chalice is a big one for
sure my channel you know Joe is a big
one I'll be working on channels like for
a long time so found channels
obviously like pain management is only
one thing your Pepsi other things too
okay I am jealous related to pain
management epilepsy a lot of things and
like autoimmune disease that all lots of
face relatives around channels like any
immune cells they're on channel you know
there aren't house to regulating the
immune cell cases so
so chemical protein synthesis could be
used for immunotherapy well I can't
develop the markers that's used for
immunotherapy because for you know
therapy now for the new checkpoints its
antibodies antibodies are attract the
most attention well I mean there are
other ways to like to go on antibodies
and I think like the current situation
we don't about is just it's too hot like
everybody's working on two bodies I mean
of course it's great so when the drugs
called some antibodies have being like
approved but I think people also needs
to focus on other classes of protein
molecules to can try to come up with
different ways to treat the disease
right if everybody is working on this
one thing like eventually I think you
can fix anything so I mean disease
cancer it's all it's all complicated
process you have to have multiple ways
or multiple strategies to come up with
one thing with to come up this and then
and then come up with strategies to
treat the disease so I don't think I
think people needs to broad out yeah so
let's so then let's talk about then the
tools so then let's say that you
identify your
are ideal targets then you come with
your suite of tools right what's in the
suite of yours yeah so now there are
different proteins we can do this
approaches all in our lab see if you
have a target you can do computational
design actually to design the protein
market to like point to the target or
you hit the target
and you start from protein design or you
can start you can just do protein
selections high-throughput protein
selection which involves protein
evolution you just do the aleutian using
different systems to come up with lead
molecules right oftentimes the things
you have in a beginning like the things
you design or the first thing you evolve
it's not it's not the perfect one
maybe the selectivity is not a high
which will give yourself effects or
maybe it's not stable enough so that
won't require further engineering and
then the chemistry can come together
come along so the chemistry that we are
working on can help you to mix the
protein molecule more stable more
selective it's just the combination of
these all your things and hopefully in
the end you come with this lead molecule
that's like selective potent and I said
so what would it look like if we were
behind the screen right now and you were
showing us how you use computer design
to make yeah proteins yeah yeah so to
design
I mean it's called structurally based
the design if how the structure of the
target protein rate oftentimes you
figure out to the active site in the
surface which parts of the protein
surface like like like us like these
parts works on what use arm works on
work if you figure out the arm of the
protein and that's the function parts
and then you see the shape of that you
try to come up with complements surfaces
like my hands it wraps around is here
right so I have to come up with the
structure that has the hand shape to
bind to here and they can hold your arm
so we used we maybe we come up with the
finger finger finger different fingers
we have a palm and they roughly place
them Indira right and they use the
computational approaches to just to
stitch these different things together
and then they hold up together even for
the you do that hand and they grab their
it done and I go yeah yeah that's not
commutation only that's not basic
concept is is there a is there parts on
the surface of proteins that are harder
to design for sure than others yeah sure
yeah so traditionally for small molecule
drug discovery we have to the require
the protein surface to have a pocket
poking means like no like you have one
dance oh it's just the operator right
and then the small can go in there and
go in there if it goes in there it has a
better chance to fit in there I
then I go but now like for many many
more targets we identify today it's just
that here is fat it's a flat surface so
let's molecule it doesn't have enough of
a surface area to interact so it doesn't
bind yeah so you can't come up with
circulate with small molecules but with
proteins because you have derive these
things like have a really big surface
area so each part of a interaction might
be weak but if you integrate all your
things together they become really
strong by it will bind and previously we
were trying to get molecules to bind and
if it was a region that didn't really
have that denter yeah area for it to go
to plus it has to be so precisely
targeted that it goes to that exact dint
yeah that area yeah so do prude you
proteins kind of have like a more rugged
like it could have different shape it
can be sticky because you know it can be
really smooth it can be rocked it some
of them you can have like pocket cuz
they bind with different things to
function if the hell Epoque you can just
go to the pocket and then you keep the
protein activity but other times just
the surface yeah there's no pocket Holly
Holly work on that yeah hurt you you
just have to have like bait protein
molecules like antibodies let's do that
okay okay Oh antibodies are big protein
molecules huge antibodies are a huge hit
yeah like how many times bigger than the
protein that wall antibody let's see
antibody has roughly 1,000 and maybe my
phone 200 or be to my father 200
universities to one
1500 1200 to 1500 a small molecule maybe
just a few amino acids size
so how many times they whoa yeah yeah
and around the size of our biggest
proteins ah well protein there are
bigger ones we have like 5,000 amino
acid proteins yeah there are some of
those but um Oh some of those they are
not just individual proteins deform
complex to work yeah but what about
these are pretty big optimal is I'm not
just a single thing either
it has different components opponent
genes yeah and the antibodies role
within our body is immune system what
yes
yeah is to identify pathologies yeah as
their clients with those and bind to the
or bind to the pathology yeah so be so
they do come out take any like
inflammation or like in your response
whatever oh yeah
and antibodies originate from what part
of our body b-cells t-cell Phoebe's
themselves he sounds so t-cells go and
hunt for the right say maybe yeah it's
so it's very complicated like you have
if a whole antigen right no I'm you
immunologist if so I'm I don't see too
much yeah a little bit yeah so like like
well antigen got inside the body like
direct Andrade cells like they just they
just swallow these antigens and then
they prevent these cells on the surface
of these generally sauce yeah
and the t-cells will interact with
another cell and they maybe didn't get
activity pizza will be involved or two
during the process
launching antibodies but you enter the
b-cells for secrets the antibody is
interesting
yeah what a incredible machinery the
body is okay and then let's talk about
like
is there one software that is the best
for protein design right now yeah
there's one it's uh it's called Rosetta
they may be called at University of
Washington this is your advisor you know
nice advisor we collaborated we were the
work I talked about we we collaborated
with in yeah okay but will that tie it
has been very powerful Rosetta is the
best by far right now of well I mean
it's the most popular was the most
popular it's the most popular yeah okay
yeah and so is it kind of like Legos
like it's kind of like click-and-drag
little little amino acids ah well it's a
degree come it's well it's a little bit
more complicated than that cuz I know
it's not Legos on the table yeah they're
just different pieces that I mean like
like I said we want to design protein
right you have like these fingers palm
you have this control you need to have
some component to start with yeah and
there you can try to see how to place
these components yes and then even
trehala one what kind of shape you want
to make yes yes so based on that you try
to connect them and then maybe have
other things to make sure they go to
this shape but then like for the
software it's like it's different
modules just try two different modules
okay so this modular yeah people don't
need to read all the codes for that you
just need to avoid any of the modules so
it's a little bit like click and drag in
that sense but then you still have to
shape it the exact way you want you
always need to see what the outcome of
that right you have a design you iran-us
you need to run simulations yeah and
then you see you you can see the result
of the simulation and then if that makes
sense
okay so you've imaged the target protein
and you know where you want your your
computer designed protein to go and
target that specific area on the target
protein and then you design via the comp
computer software the pros
right and then you then you basically
run the simulation of did it work
no it didn't work okay simulated that
and then you go okay let's adjust it
like this way and then it's like did it
work
yeah it worked better yeah and then so
is it literally like that it's not that
yeah you just keep tweaking this you
have to go you can't well well I mean
often having interferons yeah I mean
each single time it's not just one
output you have thousands all right
tens of thousands outputs you just need
to you have to come up with strategies
to rank different things and then
evaluates the results so yeah I'm making
such an interesting connection right now
from another simulation software it's
used in engineering like in
manufacturing yeah they have like a
specific part in like a car or a plane
or whatever and they they they designate
like the parameters that it needs to
that it needs to be able to hold a
certain amount of force all this kind of
stuff
it's made of a certain material right
yeah yeah and then the engineering
simulation will go through just billions
of permutations so fast and come up with
the best possible solution for that
limited space it's comparable yeah I
think it's comparable customer design we
actually I mean we roughly know this
module straight we don't really in the
beginning we we don't name it we don't
well not sure which I mean last which
specific amino acid to pull down there
so we're trying to go through this whole
process to see which have mercy fits
best
what's the best choice of this part of
that sequence and then how to make these
connections so you have to go through
all the possibilities to eventually make
this work
it's so fascinating thinking about being
able to leverage really powerful biotech
simulation to find the most optimal
chemical protein synthesis that gives
you the exact function that you want it
to do within a therapeutic effect on the
body then I mean like yeah you design
that then you design that you pray your
you might need to evolve that to a New
York so you can also synthesize that in
the year data it's it's all
complementary so it's it's just a
complementary approach and it might help
another and then so part of the bio
simulation is that you make the ideal li
chemically synthesized protein and that
it ideally targets the exact location
it's supposed to in the body so like you
have to run the bio simulation on that
part and then you have to if you could
it would be ideal that I could literally
run you I have what have your exact you
know tens of trillions of cells of your
body put together you know into this is
you know a digital twin of Bobo dung and
then I can deploy my chemically
synthesized protein into your body and
seeing digitally right on the digital
twin version before we do it on the
physical version and then see if it does
the exact therapeutic effect that we
want it to do and we can run that
billions of times to make sure it's safe
oh fast forward 20 years if anything bad
has happened you know so it's like
science fantasy yeah it's nice picture
yeah I mean if you can if you can do a
simulation at the cell level I'm so
amazing so amazing
yes it's it's just so complicated cuz
like we're just simulations Oh like
designs you have to consider every
single atom the movement every single
atom
yeah like think about how many atoms are
there meanwhile certain molecule one per
one protein molecule I think about how
many proteins in my cell yeah it's not
just the proteins they're all things -
yeah yeah but people can simulate that
it's so funny looking bad a hundred
years like it in a hundred years you
look back at this video card yeah and
you go look at them talking about how
hard it was to make a simulation of a
cell exactly like if I think about that
like how many years ago when people
start to me peptides even make like
peptide like for file and molasses long
hundred years ago it's not possible like
maybe 60 70 years ago it takes so much
effort like the first though
first chemically signifies too easily
that was made a roughly fifty sixty
years ago not took maybe one hundred
people like wow five years or maybe
you're longer to make that and now we
bring Matalin just now myself
we've also make that I can make that you
like one two one two weeks just me
myself just you by yourself can make
insulin what are two weeks in one or two
weeks yeah yeah it's about holding on
insulin market yeah yeah yeah I think
something in the markets it's already
coming to express them it's not
chemically synthesized it's not him it's
not chemically synthesized because Italy
is actually a livid you'll be tricky has
two different chains the two different
chains have like they used to be linked
to correctly together to function so I
mean for the production cost view I
think it's actually people are doing
that recombinant lee cuz people easily
it's like it's one part of a human so
you can't they can express that pretty
efficiently I love the points about like
both democratizing
Chemical protein synthesis so that we
can let people be creative and use their
creative talents and try and solve these
big health challenges but also ethically
evolving and consciously spiritually
evolving so that we don't put chemical
protein synthesis into the hands of
people that can cause bad yeah gene
synthesis yeah that actually could
happen if people want us to do that yeah
this is very important
yeah yeah that's it I mean the
technology it's not if you want to
something if not to make something bad
it's it's not that hard
yeah yeah you said you could make
insulin in one to two weeks yeah you
know when it used to take a team hundred
people and you know all this stuff
before and so like look at how much
faster it's going down and down and down
it yeah yeah I'm just gonna be able to
download the the bad thing from the
internet in the future and just have it
be made by oh yeah yeah I mean the
society is how just need some
regulations on these things like I mean
we can't control the individual
behaviors of every human being but then
like we have regulations with all laws
people follow the rules if you don't
leave a pub polished but yeah it's I
mean you can't you come somebody can
actually take these technologies to do
something but ah I like to think about
it like needing to evolve ourselves
consciously faster so that we don't have
those ooks moments and then we don't
need these extremely strict regulations
and laws also that yeah that sometimes
can hinder yeah creativity maybe people
just need to do keep education is not
part of it it's a big big part of it
yeah yeah
let's do a couple quick questions on the
way out that we like asking our guests
what would you say is the overall
meaning or purpose of life hmm
we're a medium life I think it's about
explored unknown territory every aspect
could be in science could be in nature
could be like consciousness that people
want to know what the basis of memory
what's the basis of consciousness I
think I think the meaning of life is
just is to understand these things and
maybe know where we come from it's hard
to figure out where we're going because
but figuring out where we come from
maybe it helps there from the know from
the past but it's it's it's I think it's
all about exploration like you need to
have the people need to have the spirit
to go out and to things I mean need to
they are need to believe in the things
that they might be devoted to I mean you
may not necessarily be able to do that
in your lifetime but I think it's
actually important to you have the
belief that you can do something you can
achieve something through this life I
think that's that's actually key I like
I mean I'm a big fan for O'Connor I'll
climb a lot like the spear is it's it's
the same like you have to go explore and
then explore the limits of yourself
maybe that will partially explore the
limits of the human race I think for
people if people have this mind side and
then it will be the life for I mean the
society will be more diverse like and we
need to allow these these behaviors
people need to support each other on
this so me myself like I just like this
period so I'm heading to all that
yeah pushing the boundaries of what is
known pushing the edge of knowledge
further and further going into the
unknown venturing out there yeah must
become more interesting if you do that
unless it's so boring yeah it could be
really boring for life so yeah what
about a skill that young people should
know going into the exponential
technology age the skill it's hard to
see the wine a single a specific skill I
think more maybe it's more about the
mindset you have to you have to cope you
have a keep your mind open like things
are changing all the time you know you
can't just rely on that you can you
acquire this single skill and then you
can just you're gonna stick it nice to
go out and then like to everything it's
not possible you just you need to keep
the mind open and then see what's
happening in the world and then see
maybe how you can contribute to this
world by doing the things that you can
do or maybe pushing it further to
explore all the things you haven't
thought about so I think the - idea is
actually more important than skills and
how can we inspire more people around
our world to collaborate yeah
alright collaboration for myself I just
like to work with people especially you
feel happy we work with people and then
make things work how to educate I mean
it's a long process like maybe the whole
society needs to make the effort in
there like like through schools and then
through the working with people I just
think people needs to be more open and
then eventually if the open is for what
what is to trust in people then I think
that will that will definitely help with
that but like how to how to get people
more open it's it's it's like a society
behavior like I mean people just need to
talk with other people support that it's
about people so if you do I mean if you
see things differently
I like that like the things in the u.s.
don't judge right so you have to keep
your mind open then we need to share
with people share the knowledge to share
the skills educate other people and if
everybody makes little bit effort on
their ends I think eventually people
will have more trust in each other and
then maybe Clary together yeah I think
that's my thought yeah yeah what do you
think is the role of love you know it's
critical apparently yeah I mean human I
mean not just human all life forms
essentially even sure its reproduction
that's like I mean that's the driving
force if there's no reproduction just no
driving force for the for the societal
for human of a life warm so loving love
could be like love we just I mean
reproduction is a direct result from
from love I mean love can be other
things too like now to me like just like
you go out on the street like talk to
people like encourage people in cars
fuel to explore on the words it's
encourage people to do the things they
can't do
or maybe encourage people like we have
difficulties in a life so it's grateful
people used to have love for yourself
for the people for the world do you
think that this is a simulation I think
about that actually sometimes like you
go back home right
how can you tell like okay I'll tell
with a face that the world we're living
is not it's not a dream right I mean we
feel everything right I talk to people
the things different but then I mean
could be a dream we a dream I mean we
live in your dream it's like the same if
you don't know you're dreaming right
sometimes you wake up and you feel oh I
was dreaming but maybe this whole thing
is a dream it could be but it doesn't
matter right where they streaming or not
you're still do a thing you want to do
is to explore are things you want to
explore you try to foster people don't
approach educate the people you want not
educate and then love the people I want
to love so I think it's a matter
and what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world I feel it's
like I feel like the people have the
spirit to do the things that they were
not sure if you can do and sometimes you
we are actually willing to sacrifice for
that I don't know why people wants to do
that but people can do that and there
are people doing that I think that's so
incredible
you can't explain rate I mean if you
want to if you have to if you want to
leave can't leave just just keep you
keep your life there's so many ways and
then it's also a basic instinct to keep
yourself alive but then there are so
many people trying to push the
boundaries and then sometimes it costs
it costs the life even but then people
still have the spirit to do that hello I
mean it's hard to explain but that thing
I think that the action makes you feel
your life is fulfilling you are teaming
your your your you're not proving to you
are not proved you're thrown into other
people that you worthy it's just like
it's just a matter of yourself like I
want to do that and I feel happy doing
that so that's the that's the really I
want to do that and I will do that and I
think that's the thing yeah we really
love calling it like the burden of
genius that you take on this amount of
responsibility and you just go and bring
this unique gift to the world and it's
just such a gorgeous feeling and
experience to go through that journey
and to bring value yeah yeah yeah
sometimes you may not know clearly
you're pretty you're creating some value
but you are so people needs to do that
we call each other yes well sure yeah
but well this has been such a pleasure
and thank you so we're talking about a
show yeah appreciate it
thanks for all your great work yeah
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about protein technologies about
protein engineering about chemical
synthesis and about how this can be
therapeutic for our lives so we can
unlock biology and on the simulation
side as well also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world that you believe and help them
grow you can find all of Bobo in his
labs link below you can find westlakes
links below you can reach out to them
and join them in their efforts if you'd
like and collaborate you can find our
links below to our show you can support
us and help us grow help us continue
doing cool things like coming to
Hangzhou and doing interviews at
Westlake with brilliant people and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world you love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
good job oh man let me talk
[Music]